I think there's been a lot of
misrepresentation when it comes to
freedom of the press
we don't extremely very well you rank a
hundred and twentieth out of a hundred
and eighty countries it's not a glorious
record is it minister i think it's a lot
of ignorance and a lot o far
miss chief another assumption has to be
that you're covering up damaging
evidence doesn't it those alligators
occur are true and she's been taking
care of despite promises to respect the
rule of law Nigeria's government stands
accused by the international community
of serious human rights abuses my guest
this week here in London is Lima Hamid
the country's information minister
how does he defend against the country's
many critics when the evidence of
wrongdoing is so compelling
[Music]
[Music]
like Muhammad welcome to conflict zone
thank you sir
the human rights record of your
administration has been widely condemned
by the UN Western countries your own
lawyers International Human Rights
bodies for brutality and the stunning
lack of accountability why does this go
on in Nigeria why don't you get a grip
on this I think there's been a lot of
misrepresentation by all these groups
absolutely really working in concert
well I already know that working consent
and they're working you know alone but I
know for a fact that dissolution in
particular has been very sensitive to
the issue of human rights most sometimes
terrorists politicians activists are
confused with human rights so you put it
all down to confusion I would do that
because I do not know as a fact and I'd
be Minister for almost five years that
there's any policy of my administration
that deliberately targeted at infringing
on anybody's right Minister last
September the UN Special Rapporteur on
extrajudicial summary or arbitrary
executions
agnus calamar she launched a damning
report on Nigeria as I'm sorry and the
human rights abuses of your security
forces she said she spoke of countrywide
patterns of abuses include the police
and military's excessive use of lethal
lethal force in violation of applicable
international standards I'm sure you've
read the report hey she's not a person
who makes these accusations lightly well
I I did but I would have be much more
impressed if examples
a given now
you must not forget that Daniels been
locked in a war of attrition with the
book quorum for almost a decade
and the kind of war were fighting is a
war amongst people and even then the
military has been very careful to ensure
that as much as possible rights are not
violated now I've also read about
reports of people who claim that the
return validated simply because they've
been arrested by any of these security
agencies and they've been asked to go
sit through what are called due process
but I notice a policy this government
does not violate anybody's right if it's
not a matter of policy why have there
been so few investigations the UN
investigators spoke about the absence of
meaning of effective investigations the
absence of meaningful prosecution all of
which are compounded she said by the
lack of transparency over the vast
majority of security issues that
accusation about lack of transparency
and effective communication strategy
goes straight to your door minister
doesn't it
you are the Minister of Information
serious criticism here well what I know
as a fact that several keys of abuse of
you know rights really akin sutures have
not only been investigated but but
people have been punished and they be
made public how many how many people
okay I don't know of yet but I know the
minister of information was of course I
can know everything but I never I know
that the military also is very jealous
of his reputation and they have set up
many you know panels and affected
officers have either been dismissed or
imprisoned
the International Criminal Court isn't
isn't impressed by your record it says
in 2018 there was a reasonable basis to
believe that the Nigerian security
forces committed the war crimes of
murder torture cruel treatment outrages
upon personal dignity and intentionally
directing attacks against the civilian
population but you have failed to
cooperate with the investigators and
fail to provide information that they
requested and if you take these things
seriously and you cannot but take the
word of the International Criminal Court
seriously you would have provided that
information why didn't you I didn't what
information they were asking for
I was not provided but I knew that would
be cooperating with every agency spirit
when it comes to as I said they weren't
they weren't getting help from you they
weren't getting the information I know
the term the ICC met with the
authorities in Korea and we would have
no choice number to cooperate they've
been waiting for years to get your
cooperation and it hasn't come Minister
maybe you're out of the loop here what
maybe you don't have information about
what's going on in your own government
I'm very informed focus on my government
and I was yeah actually I do take the
trouble to ask and I'm not like a CA I'm
not aware that we have withdrawn our
cooperation from the ICC the UN Special
Rapporteur speaks of countless
allegations of excessive use of force by
your police in particular Offices of the
special anti robbery squad or SARS you
said you wanted specific examples these
are specific examples they've been
accused of widespread torture in some
cases leading to deaths in custody and
extrajudicial killings so the unit is
clearly out of control isn't it because
the UN Human Rights Committee warned
your government to ensure that this
group operates in accordance with
international standards because they
don't trust that it's doing that at the
moment why would that be is that I think
I'm aware of that and
at a point in time when the report came
out the SAS was disbanded and only to be
reconstituted and you know want that
ends fourth they must show that they
operate within the confines of the law
your own National Human Rights
Commission investigated their activities
it even held public hearings but the
results were never published why I'm not
aware that I'm not aware the general
assumption has to be that you're
covering up damaging evidence doesn't it
which you're afraid to I don't think we
have compelling damaging evidence some
policemen were dismissed the entire SAS
was disbanded and reorganized thereafter
Minister on the question of providing
information to outside investigators you
failed to provide information to the UN
under the International Covenant on
Civil and Political Rights which Nigeria
has signed last August the treaty body
accused you of failing to honor your
reporting obligations and the article 40
of the Covenant and ignoring numerous
reminders to do so why is that when you
tell me you're cooperating so openly
with these bodies why would they say
that what if it wasn't true I wouldn't
know why do you say that but I know that
we have never shown any interest
novelisation as possible for any country
who is waging an internal you know whose
father internal you know insurgency very
open and we will preach with the
international you know regulations and
laws well clearly you don't according to
the bodies that monitor these situations
well it depends for it it depends on
from which perspective they get the
information
well they're getting it from different
perspectives on time we're talking about
human rights organizations international
human rights organizations we're talking
about the UN we're talking about all
kinds of bodies the International
Criminal Court they're all saying the
same thing that you're not cooperating a
new city earth in front in front of me
minister and say that that's simply not
true
it's like saying it's darkness outside
when we can see its daily no no I think
that knowledge is not correct I know
that daily we receive we entertain and
we engage all these bodies as a
government and you're not going to move
from that version despite the evidence
we have to see any evidence the term not
responded to it when you talked about
size yes I admitted that yes it will be
pursued report and we took action mister
when you not stonewalling on request for
information you're taking radio stations
off the air and having reporters
arrested or beaten June last year you
tried shutting down Nigeria's oldest
private TV channel as well as radio
stations owned by a member of the
opposition PDP Raymond doc Pacey a
federal court overturned your suspension
that the Nigerian guild of editors
called this a barbaric crackdown on free
speech why are you launching a barbaric
crackdown on free speech I think it's a
lot of ignorance and a lot of mischief
the editors don't read the PUC's station
were lost down because he owed the
national regulator not because of the
news he was pushing out and in January
last year soldiers raided the offices of
one of your leading papers the daily
trust and arrested reporters in March a
journalists have been held for two years
was read you rank a hundred and
twentieth out of 180 countries in the
Press Freedom Index of reporters without
borders it's not a glorious record is it
minister well
I think when it comes to freedom of the
press
we don't extremely very well if papers
wrong foul of the law they must face the
consequences
but when you have virtually a hundred
newspapers in the country and you're
citing the example of oneness we but I
was closed down within the year I think
she'd be fair to us that we have a very
robust free press Amnesty International
says that between January and September
last year at least 19 journalists and
media practitioners were attacked those
attacks include verbal and physical
assault and indiscriminate arrest and
detention by your security forces if the
impression Minister is therefore that
your aim seems to be to stifle freedom
of expression especially critical voices
you don't like criticism do you that
that's not correct you see because I
think many of these people don't want
this don't know the ecosystem of the
media in Nigeria virtually every major
you know print media is owned by
individuals and I can tell you that this
there is about 12 national newspapers
and trust daily trust I thought I can't
quite remember what the story was but
you cannot take the example of one
newspaper among about 20 to say that the
country is stifling the media on the
contrary at the point in time I felt
that was the government was actually the
recipient of the media what has also
worried people enormous ly is your
decision to submit a bill which in its
original form would have seen anyone
convicted of so-called hate speech
actually sentenced to death by hanging
and the particular circumstances you
actually wanted a new sort or is a ssin
from Parliament to kill people because
of something they said why would you do
a thing like that extraordinary and
shocking provision I think what is even
more shocking is the ignorance of people
there's what is cost oppression of power
you know in major democracies
this particular be talking about is it
builds up it yet not by the executive
Papaji legislation but in STD panel
government so how can you accuse the
executive you submitted you submitted
this we did not is also the sort of
ignorance we did not this this is a
private member's bill by a senator which
is the yes and you're telling me you
didn't want it to go through is that
right
we do have a choice in with which bills
go through or not the bill has been
discussed there's public hearing what
did you see the government does not come
in or - when the bill has been passed
and you didn't use any influence to get
that data so that's absolutely none if
this bill had gone through Minister
journalists could have been jailed for
any article deemed threatening abusive
or insulting and could have been hanged
if their work caused any loss of life
where you didn't object to this bill you
don't see this what is called dodging of
the personal power the only thing you
can do as the president is refuse your
assent sochi law the law has not been
passed the lot but was not originated by
the executive the law is still going
through the siRNA so how the hell did i
just miss a president stop it would have
been accused of no dictatorship um and
muslin d you telling me you wouldn't
have signed the law with that provision
in it I think this you can't tell me
that can you had this speculative you
can when we get when yet that Beach
right across it will look at what are
the contents of that law in what form
will it be passed but you see people
rushed you know to history literature to
judgment you can't even touch upon that
you said we submitted that that's bill
we did not we know not even wanted
submitted
we don't micromanage the Parliament what
about the protection from internet
falsehood and manipulations bill also
carrying draconian provisions under its
terms journalists could be in prison for
publishing content
author of that bill are you against this
bill or not I'm not even aware of that
bill you're not the protection from
internet falsehood and manipulations
bill you're not even aware of it so it
cannot ecozy it's causing it's causing
an outcry internationally and you're the
Minister of Information and I nothing
about no such bill before the house
there is a bill I can say that authority
natively there is no saki bill before
the House reporters without borders said
these bills talking about the
prohibition of hate speech bill and the
protection from internet for so the
manipulations bill they said these bills
contain extremely harsh penalties that
violate international law and are likely
to be used to gag the media and you were
saying you know nothing about this just
the same way they were wrong in saying
that the people submitted the hate
speech bill mister let's talk about
corruption because in your country it
seems to begin with the government
doesn't it the International Center for
Investigative Reporting said last year
that among nine countries in sub-saharan
Africa Nigeria has the worst managed
sovereign wealth fund based on
accountability transparency and
oversight
why is your record so bad absolutely
force really absolutely false report by
the National Resource Institute's Africa
office based on data from 2017 said you
had failed to regularly disclose
publicly the financial interests of
government officials in the extractive
sector all the identities of beneficial
owners of extractive companies despite
making public commitments to do so it's
obviously forces the first thing you do
the first obligation as the minister or
the public official is ready to make a
public declaration of all your assets
and any Minister public official who
does not do so risk being prosecuted and
we know many who are not been prosecuted
as a result of that to is to the credit
of this administration that only a few
months ago we passed you know we put in
in your input
is a policy that compels every ministry
every department to make public and
expenditure above ten thousand powers so
that the public can challenge what is
being spent for it's also the catalyst
obsession that no government has ever
succeeded in securing the completion of
high-profile politicians by
demonstration and spraying those of the
new blunders William party we continue
to fight corruption because and you fir
and you follow the rules do you
absolutely
so in 2018 why in towards the close of
president Bill Harris first term why did
the Auditor General himself race series
concerned about this so-called excess
crude account that you have this is an
oil savings account which holds dollar
reserves from crude oil that are sold
above the assumed benchmark price and in
July that year the Auditor General
warned you to bring your handling of
this account into line with the law why
if you tell me you follow the rules did
you see precisely because he said it -
without us
purity insertion is the other Dodaro is
an appointee shows how shocking he
thinks your behavior actually is no as
no on the contrary really it shows the
level of transparency in the
administration that an appointee of
government can say this and yet retain
his job he knows it had been deductions
from the account which appear to have
been made illegally in other words
deductions that apparently violated
constitutional provisions why would that
be and why would he say that if you are
following the rules and you tell me what
you see
everywhere in the world live in the most
web no democracies you have auditor
terrors you have what Auditor General
yes yes and their duty is to monitor the
excesses of government now the fact that
is allowed to do that job and the theory
means in office I think it's a testament
to the fact that were renovators bread
you know administration the effect if
one congratulations for
I was gonna forget from you as opposed
to criticism from the Auditor General
who says you not in line with the law
with that you don't think that matters
but it is to the to the correctness or
not of that you know allegation the fact
that he can make that allegation
submitted he's been looking on his TV
middle that there I think it's that will
not happen Nick in a demonstration that
does not believe in trance be said the
audit team could find no legal authority
for even the existence of this excess
crude account so it's a sham and a slush
fund isn't it why don't why don't you
admit it admit that yeah
yeah there's no legal basis for this for
this account you know I don't think it's
correct to say that there's no legal
basis what because they could the crude
oil called the excess account have known
about it even before we came to
government it said
the audit team could find no legal
authority for even the existence of this
excess crude account how come you did no
persistent warnings from the Auditor
General as he said year after year not
just your government but the previous
one going back to 2007 to bring this in
line with the law again you tell me you
follow the rules but it's not backed up
by the order to check we follow the
rules and like even that allegation is
even better certain is correct the old
idea of auditor general is to point out
to you what you are doing wrong and for
you to do it right I don't see any
government in the world that they say oh
we always follow the law we always do
everything correctly but I see again the
fact that data recommend the report and
nothing has happened him is still in
office yes and and what you continue to
make illegal deductions from the account
well it depends what you might indicate
illegally in an illegal deduction
deductions that violated constitutional
provisions it's not you see
if if a government violates
constitutional provision it is the
resolution of the Parliament to take
appropriate action but I don't believe
that we do responsibility of the
government if it cares about the P
was money to Mendez ways isn't it of
course but that's if you admit that you
have even loss but I what I'm saying is
that yes they all general could have
found some normal ease the OL essence of
of the de girar everywhere in the world
that there will be checks and balances
and all you know for the dirty is that
there are some irregularities and then
the appropriate you know I'm of God
meant you would do the needful so what
are you going to do in future about this
I'm sure it has been an iffy what are
you going to do if those alligators are
true I'm sure he's been taking care of
well it hasn't been and he's been
reporting and complaining about the
government's attitude to this account
since 2007
just as the UN has green complaining
that you haven't been giving information
about torture and excesses of violence
used by your security forces as the
International Criminal Court has been
complaining all these complaints are
piling up Minister what are you going to
do in the future about them we don't
walk we look at every completes we look
at our there and we take action like
I've told you that minute
severa what Macias many military
officers have been killed some have been
dismissed and it's now our interest
Global Witness says despite a 50-year
oil boom which transformed Nigeria's
economy into the largest in Africa
eighty percent of your people live on
less than $2 a day they say that an
estimated 400 billion dollars has gone
missing from state coffers are you gonna
tell the people of Nigeria where that
money is gone under our watch between
2015 and 2019
nobody can suppress such and such
allegation and I can only speak for when
I became Minister and I can see it agree
that between 2015 and today nobody can
talk about all money missing my Mohammed
thanks very much for being on conflict
so thank you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]